they rolled up itself plant-strong
people who came in the mail today so we
got a care package
courtesy of Compton at Ascended health
you saw the logo on the back of the
shirt Compton is a guy that I've been
working with on some really cool
nutrition nutrition products and and
specifically plant-based products for
recovery and just overall wellness so
I've been using these products for a
while at home and ran out and come to
the sent us some refills so I'll go in
later on in a different video I'll go
into like what everything is but you
know essentially it just got some skin
oils and some special water and we got
this is the special plant based recovery
powder which is which has a bunch of
really cool stuff in it like special
marine phytoplankton resveratrol which
is a super powerful antioxidant and some
adaptogens and maca that Compton gets
from his secret source in South America
so this is good stuff and one of the
cornerstones is his green endurance
formula which I'm told he's continued to
refine and it's supposed to be amazing
basically it's it has a lot of enzymes
in it and sort of live cultures and it's
all plant-based but one of the things is
that in transit as you can see the
bottle is quite distended so it's
there's a lot of pressure in this thing
and we're a little afraid to open it so
yeah we already opened up one of them
and it took off like a rocket so we're
actually going in the bathroom right so
we're gonna go on the shower and open
this one up and see what happens but
basically this is something that we
drink in the morning just one glass of
it you know it's just basically no we're
all well this booster and endurance
booster so let's go in the shower and
see what happens when we open this a
real quick roll doc I just want to show
the viewers what we did at the farmers
market today and look how beautiful that
looks right there Apple bananas we got
some star fruit right this any more
oh wow you got the watermelon that's
right beautiful we got another care
package in an El roll oh yeah we got Sun
warrior from a team care of Lucy Thank
You Lucy
thanks Compton thanks Lucy so where's
our Sun warrior it's right there in our
box
yeah this is great hey let's give a
shout out let's give a shout out to
Rebecca in California for sending us our
all of our goods we get stuff shipped in
that we can't get here on the island
Rebecca thank you we love you
here's the Sun warrior protein it comes
in chocolate and vanilla raw vegan rice
protein this stuff is excellent and it
doesn't have any of that gritty kind of
stuff that a lot of protein powders have
it's just you know melts right in your
gym you guys you can go to Sun warrior
calm that's right you can order it up
there to get product here's the other
thing that that they offer which is this
activated barley it's another endurance
boosting product and the stuff is great
too so you put that over so we can get
that website there it is right there
some warrior calm calm okay okay so cool
we're going to be digging some of that
all right let's hit the shower dun duh
dun dun dun duh dum dum he said it was
rocket fuel let's see what happens
should I just pop it open or do it slow
now I think these up do it real
slow and then tighten it back up real
quick do it real slow and tighten it
back up real quick there you go just now
you hear that me just once not going to
explode
like that place so you could smell it
what does that smell like to be honest
baby someone that oh there you go good
work
hold on there it goes again
dude we got how we gonna do just like
that just like that well do you see that
yeah
well that guy just went
Compton yeah pumped and Bruce's stuff up
in his kitchen this kitchens like a lab
you know he's always testing new
plant-based products trying to come up
with nutritional and wellness stuff and
we should check out his website at
Senate health calm he's doing some
amazing stuff and the Senate Health has
a storefront where's the location
someone that I have a kidney in Venice
Venice Beach and the skeletal animus
addict I became villars right so uh but
he's an ass he's a PhD in biochemistry
and really devoted to to wellness and
he's really trying out has some amazing
stuff so might not be pretty but I
assure you that this is amazing stuff so
we're gonna test it out what you know
I'm going to throw that Sunday felt calm
thanks Carlton hey Compton we appreciate
it thank you for giving us up for 2009
Ultraman World Championships busi Sun
warrior the goddess we love you thank
you for the support